Here are four frequently asked questions that many interviewees find hard to answer.
Number One. "Tell me about yourself."
Here, you need to talk about what you have to offer, your experiences, skills and strengths.
Concentrate on what they want in an applicant.
Number Two. "Why are you leaving your job?"
The interviewer is testing whether there were any problems and if you might become a problem.
Change the focus and reword the answer to emphasize the positive.
Number Three. "Why do you want to work here?"
Talk about your research about the company, their policies and mission statement.
Or else, say that you've attended the interview to find out if...
...this would be the right place for you.
Number Four. "What is your weakness?"
Always a difficult one, because you might give the interviewer a lot of information with your shortcomings.
Mention a negative aspect, but tell how this could also be seen positively,...
...or mention what you are doing to overcome the weakness.